research interests include
bioinformatics and computational
genomics multi-platform and multi-scale
data analysis and integration genomics
and epigenomics of common health
diseases
pathway prediction and modeling gene
regulatory networks as well knowledge
and uh drug discovery using big data and
dr shindo hits would be giving a talk on
bioinformatics and computational
genomics research and training over to
you dr schindler
all right yeah sure thank you very much
for that great introduction and
i wish to thank the pine bio
organizing committee for
allowing us to share
the information about the activities
going on our
lab
so uh i guess i'll wait for dr kasuras
to exit before i share the screen
yes dr shinder you can share your screen
you have the permissions
[Music]
i i guess see the screen is not being
shared yet
it was shared and then i think it went
away maybe you can try it
okay
so let's see
so can you see my screen
no we can see your video but we don't
see your screen
okay
what about now now we can yep
okay let me see
all right this is okay now
yeah maybe you need to share the other
screen we see your view not the
presenter view
oh okay
uh so what about this yep perfect
okay
all right so thank you very much to
everyone and thank you very much for
inviting me to share the information
about the
some of the activities that are going on
on the adversary center here
in new orleans
so i'm going to focus mainly on the uh
the bioinformatics and computational
genomics research and training program
opportunities that are here
uh in louisiana i i would like to
mention also that
we are part of lsu just like dr kashmiri
talks about so we are basically here at
the medical center that we are in
uh and then a lot of the information
that i'll provide obviously if you have
questions
uh you are also welcome to reach us
through
you can either call me or by cell phone
or by vocal phone or by
email or any
medium that you present and in the event
that you miss some of the information
you can also just google lsu
bioinformatics and you will find us
there where we have various programs
that i'll be talking about
so what i would like to talk about
mainly is the bioinformatics and
genomics program and i'm going to focus
on the
opportunities
under the three
missions of the university the first
mission is the research mission i'm in
the best department with department of
genetics
so research for us
is a commission
we also have research under the service
support which essentially means that
apart from conducting our own research
we also provide other
investigators in the states
and also in the region
with bioinformatics services support
the other part that i'll talk about is
the education mission where we have
various
opportunities uh we have a newly
established master's program in
bioinformatics which is a degree program
which essentially means that you can get
a formal training say for example
through pine bio
and then you can also punctuate that
with the
uh a formal training program where you
actually uh get the degree so
essentially for example paintball will
provide you with a foundation
and then you can come here and have a
formal training
and get the
degree
or we will basically discuss with time
bio to see maybe how we can manage those
programs
there's also a summer program in
bioinformatics which is also which is a
funded program essentially you can also
you can just apply to that program
and
then we will select you if you qualify
and basically work with us for 10 weeks
and during those 10 weeks you'll get a
paycheck
therefore you don't have to go looking
for a summer job for that
we have the outreach program which
essentially means that we train students
from
neighboring institutions especially
historical black colleges
like xavier d land southern university
and others
we also have the international program
which we participate in with the various
countries particularly most at this
point mostly with the
african countries
and then we are involved in technology
development which i'll also talk about a
little bit
so
uh this is a program we have very a very
new program and very few people but
we leverage our
uh expertise here uh with expertise in
the
uh at the neighboring universities or
with other collaborating partners
internationally and in the region
so there is myself at the director there
is doctor wilson about information and
they took this idea which he was a
bioinformatics analyst and we take him
bioinformatics as i said uh
bioinformatics and computational
economics graduate students so right now
we have david odofne from nigeria which
recently joined our lab we have currents
from india
and a joint program with uab
uh the program itself i said is located
at the medical center here
and this is our website
and through this website you can
click on each one of these uh put down
screens
and you can find additional information
including our publications and all the
activities that we are involved in
we do we do as i said we provide
bioinformatics services
uh we conduct genomic research adobe
cooperative research
and then education and you can reach us
through here
so in terms of setup this is basically
the way our lab is set up
or just when you sit you basically sit
like back to back you don't face like
one direction sit back to back but our
lab is set up this way now the reason
i'm showing this slide means like dr
kasu has mentioned in the preacher's
presentation
we do have the capability to collaborate
with partners around the world so we get
data from around the world uh through
various platforms for example
right now we collaborate with
the university of cape town in south
africa we can get data from there
we do use the globus platform
that allows us to
perform collaborative research and
collaborative data sharing the global
platform social media
we can move data from anywhere
on the globe
uh to our lab using the robust nodes
provided with that other end has also
got the global snort
so if you are working with us
this would be the setup whether you are
a phd student or whether you are in our
master's program or even if you are in
the outreach program
so
in terms of research basically this is
basically the five domains of research
that we are involved in but i want also
to mention that
we are not restricted to human research
we can do any type of bioinformatics
with is the animal sciences
plant sciences we can do
uh it's all genetics
and unfortunately
i have worked in both the humans as well
as the animals and plants so therefore i
feel have
an understanding of
what is in bioinformatics genetics
interactiveness genetics whether you are
working on animals or plants or humans
uh it's just a matter of semantics so
how you can formulate a question
that you would like to address but these
are the programs that we work on
in addition to the listed the three five
programs that i show here you'll see a
green line showing here simply means
that this is predictive modeling
basically where we are using machine
learning and other algorithms uh to
predict different uh diseases for
example
uh we are working quite a lot with the
alabama genomics
the alabama genomics initiative where we
genotype a lot of people and we are
using genotype information
to basically develop photogenic risk
scores essentially means that you can
predict the disease risk
of the
of an individual
or how to stratify those patients and
that also involved that although these
are divided in quadrants here
we do a lot of data integration in my
lab
that
we integrate various pieces of
information
so that
we can improve the outcome or improve
the predictability
of the
algorithms
by basically refining them an example
would be
can you integrate genotype data for
example with the
array music
to
refine the predictiveness of that
algorithm
so
we also develop technologies of course
as i said we support other people other
than our own initiative for research so
we have developed the pipelines
these are the pipelines that he
uh those who are cooperating with us and
those who need access to that to us
through service support i can access
this so the pipeline that i have listed
here basically they are not all of them
as you know
every bioinformatics question depends on
the investigator but these are the main
ones so we have
capabilities for our migraine data
analysis
and the also genotype data analysis
essentially for microarray platforms
we have rna-seq data analysis pipelines
exome sequencing analysis pipeline
genome
for genome sequencing
we have recently developed a single cell
analysis timelines
and we have developed also methylation
analysis pipelines these pipelines that
i'm listing here
are backed up by our publications so
that the investigators who are
cooperating with us can actually see
that
we are not only saying that we can do
this but we actually have expertise in
this and those are demonstrated
expertise uh which is very critical as
dr kasuras mentioned that he is very
critical for grant applications because
you cannot just list the names but they
want to see can you actually
uh do that with their in evidence that
you have actually done that as you see
these are disaggregated algorithms here
or disaggressive platforms they are
nowhere near where pine bio is buying
pine barrel has an integrated
environment we haven't reached the uh
integrated
environments
obviously so
but this saves us well because partly
because we are also researchers we are
not only liking uh developers of the
tools
therefore
our algorithms for example deliveries
with say the pine bio or the tibial
platform
so
what do we do so these are other
expertise that we have we do a lot of
copy number variation mutation profile
mutation spectrum
and the imitation rates manipulation
profiling arrangement sequencing pathway
analysis uh so these are some of the
things that we can do obviously we can
also do some other which are out outside
this house room for example we go
through chipset data analysis we do a
lot of proteomics data analysis here
um
because we have an actually an active
proteomics call here
so
i just wanted to give you a little bit
about
some small demos about the things that
we have done as i said we've been able
to we have done a lot of genotyping so
here's an example of what we can do
uh so for example we have
uh this is genotype data from 350 000
cases and controls uh basically these
are genotypes people now we don't have
to genotype these ourselves basically we
can get data from public domain for
example this data is coming from db gap
uh which is basically
nih but it has access so from there we
can analyze here as you see on the right
side here uh we can analyze base study
uh the snips uh mutation for general
invitations
at what you see at the top of these are
simple chromosomes this is just a
manhattan
manhattan probe
protein mapping the snips
to the chromosomes
and on the right side here you can see
the low key value essentially we can use
this with the threshold here so
basically we can compare cases to
controls and identify those mutations
fortunately this was what we used to do
uh
[Music]
in like 10 15 years ago but now you can
do sequence based uh genome-wide
association studies you don't have to do
genotyping
so for example here's a cartoon showing
exactly what i just showed you before
there let's just take a tune with
basically different snips mapped to
different chromosomes and the color
codes simply means for different genes
for different diseases for example
it would be cancer
heart disease or anything that you work
on so this is simply aggregating the
snips and marking them to the
chromosomes
and then
we can do this so this means that you
can also do analysis across diseases or
across cancer types or anything that you
are interested or you can use these
resources which are also available to
the nih
website that you can also use these
resources as a reference reference
resources but i wanted to highlight is
that these are the snips that we are
actually using for
developing algorithms like polygen risk
scores
as i mentioned we also original
sequencing here as you can see we work
very much on triple negative resistance
and here basically what we are looking
is sequencing different genomes of
breast cancer and comparing it to
different uh two different types of
manageable negative cancer triple
negative cancer for those who are don't
worry in this area simply means that
it's negative for the three parts for
the three markers estrogen receptor
progesterone receptor and the human
epidemic
received a growth factor receptor so if
it's negative for that then it's
classified as triple negative cancers
but the basic premise here is the
sequencing of the genomes of
people who are diagnosed with triple
negative cancer and comparing to
determining are there any differences
between the genome the triple negative
genome and the other
genomes so basically you can
you can wait with us on that
and then you can see here basically
classification of different mutations
different genetic alterations they
understand the range of base pairs
and things like that so these are things
that you can do with us in terms of
collaborative research again it doesn't
have to be that you work on tree but you
get a dance they would do it on
something entirely different
that will be graduate with you but this
is just the functional based
uh classification of mutations uh on the
left side here you can see the genes
here and different mutations
for example this is we have copy number
variance
point mutation space that is like his
snips and then simply marking them if
for example you have exam sequence data
you can map them to the 3d structure and
determine where they located are they
inside
on top of the surface of the structure
inside the structure backbone or
whichever way
you are studying that becomes
very important for the people who are
studying
uh drug development
so
uh you can also do functional analysis
through that see where they located do
they actually disrupt the enhancers or
promoters and
are they microarray
located in
microsoft actually uh
looked at this problem uh in terms of
looking at sleeps where whether they
disrupt the alternatives pricing in that
way we have actually published in our
previous reports
we do a lot of
data integration on a small scale
definitely no way i gave me a t-bio but
we do integration of germline and
somatic limitations so here we have the
germline genome that i just showed and
then we have the cancer genome and then
basically we integrate that information
and then we can look at
for example
the genes which contain germline
mutations also contain somatic mutations
and for example those pathways that he
control the german genome also
controlling the uh the cancer genome
this is going to be uh very important
very important as we move through our
predictive modeling where we have to
look at the genetic precision
predisposition versus the uh the disease
uh itself so that's it other than just
predicting the outcomes which we do now
uh we see say tumor data uh we may also
be used to start looking at
uh how to predict the disease risk uh
and that means that
other than focusing on me uh what is now
body uh precision medicine or genomic
erasing but we may also have to be
looking at the precision prevention for
example if we can predict genetic
predisposition
that is thanks to a disease so so that's
how we are looking at that we have also
introduced a new dimension to this
rather than looking at the gem line and
somatic imitation we have also
introduced the
epigenetic
data there so for example in this
cartoon you can see here we have gene
expression data here we have mentioned
data
and also the genotype and the gene the
the rationale here is basically to
determine
uh where the somatic mutations or
general mutations are located are those
menstruated regions so that is very
important to determine whether
menstruation actually does mediate the
interactions between the germline genome
and the uh somatic genome so
also as you know
epigenetics is notifiable therefore if
we would
determine that
therefore things like studying like the
biology of behavior that might become
quite interesting uh in the sense that
they are certain factors that would be
modifiable factors for example basically
and other mobilities
that can be modified
and how that relates to epigenetic
regulation because we can't modify the
the general and genome
but we can modify the other factors so
that's the research part
so what about the service part the
service by the basically we have various
ways we have the various models uh one
is through cooperative research mode
where we write the grants together with
you and then basically we are all on the
grant uh the other part would be uh
where we basically just do a project
based analysis where we say well this
project maybe the investigator says
i don't have enough money so i can't
budget for bioinformatics say i i i can
buy it for my information but only a
small piece and then it will say okay so
this is a project whereby so for example
this would be pirate studies they order
postdocs and students do pilot studies
they are funded by lbrn or other
organizations and maybe we'll say okay
just so budget say one thousand dollars
for
bioinformatics and that will be project
based uh collaboration then there's a
fee for service where i will say okay
i'll just pay you a fee you do the wait
for me tell me how many hours it will
take and i'll do faithful service uh so
in this cartoon i'm just showing that
everybody who does service support knows
that uh this discussion always happens
whereby information goes there with your
laptop and the physician on the other
side here they are the other guys so
this is still made the bioinformatician
is once known how
what is the objective of the program
well what is the outcome of the analysis
and the on the other hand the physician
is saying tell me how many samples do i
need those kind of things so all these
statues are there so on the far left
here i'm showing that
there's a table here
that we have so that is something that
uh we wanted to collaborate with
resolve the program
before actually the project takes place
so that's the uh cooperation we do have
other cooperation here which is the
uh
collaboration with the precision
medicine program which is also here
where we have the information coming
from the physicians ordering the tests
and we are doing the bioinformatics
variant calling and giving them the
report card there
and then they can report that back to uh
to the patient so that's the safest part
uh then we also uh have been working on
using a service but also we do data
mining for example in this category here
we are helping the people to
use the cover genome atlas as a
validation to the
experiments that they themselves
performed
so recently we just published actually a
copy paper
on that from louisiana
using this uh genome atlas from
from harvard as the
uh the validation
procedure
so the bioinformatics opportunities here
we do have as i said the master's
program here is a joint program between
the universe between the graduate school
and the school of medicine is a two-year
program with 10 courses
plus a thesis is the best project driven
program
basically it has the 36 credit hours
and the these are the faculty here uh so
we have the co-fought with bester who
teach that is the basically
interdisciplinary program uh i teach
bioinformatics and computational
genomics doctor who teaches the
bioinformatics programming dr terra
metagenomics dr lynn about statistics uh
uh dr hollenberger dr mundo they teach
molecular genetics i gained
biostatistics here
and also dr guiller teaches you things
like
things where compliers
ah then we also in addition to that we
have the program is enriched by bringing
the external that likely dr philip says
dr campio said uh so the program is
really enriched by bringing people with
expertise from outside so that the
students don't only listen to us but
they can also listen to other
people who are very well accomplished
from outside for example here dr jonas
almeida is the
director of the data science service
center for the mci
uh mohamed haines in industry and dr jay
park from
actual lsu center for computational
biology
and many others that we bring them here
this is basically to enrich the program
and so that students can also discuss
what are the
uh what are the other opportunities for
example under this same program we would
bring someone like dr campio and say
okay can you
for example enrich our program by
telling our students what are the
opportunities outside there other than
what we uh tell them
these are some of the students graduate
students who have graduated yes uh sorry
we're just a little bit over time um and
uh before we have a chance to um do you
have a a lot more slides we we have some
questions that people have no actually
i'm almost there okay i think i've
probably one slide or two
here so here are some of the graduates
students who have used our program who
have graduated from our program using
bioinformatics services and some of the
new students here
and this is the summer program here
where there's got all these students
that we have trained under the summer
program so i don't need to spend a lot
of time on this because this information
actually
on our website but i wanted to share
with you that actually we do
these things and we list where these
students are they have graduated from
this program and where they are now
this is an international program between
us and south africa zambia and tanzania
recently uh so we are involved in
different programs they are around the
globe as well
i do participate myself in the power net
which is part of the h3 africa
training program and these basically are
the funding agencies
and with that i should i would say thank
you and uh certainly if there are any
questions i can answer or maybe i can
answer at the end of the program
uh so for being too wrapped uh to click
on this one that again this information
is available i only would have come to
reach me uh even through dr kasura so
through india your authorities will
reach me if in case you lose my
information thank you very much
okay thank you very much dr um cendo